voilà je vous propose dès à présent
notre rétro au calme vous connaissez
cette fameuse réplique t'as de beaux
yeux tu sais et c'est ce que pouvait
dire les membres du jury du festival de
cannes à leur présidente il y a quinze
ans en 1977 il s'agissait en effet de
michel maure gand gent croci
j'ai essayé de dormir un petit peu parce
que je n'avais pas beaucoup dormi dans
le train et je suis arrivé sous ainsi
aller griller
et orageux et voilà il fait beau
maintenant
quand je trouve particulièrement pas
excitant l'érotisme
je trouve que l'érotisme se dépense
commençant par 06 menace on en parle
tellement on parle tellement de tort de
copier on en a tellement plein le dos de
de tous
et oui c'était bien en 1971 15 ans déjà
qu